Telltale Games has revealed that they're
bringing multiplayer to the upcoming
Batman the telltale series with the new
crowd play feature as reported by shaft
news crowd play was announced at Comic
Con and will allow other players to take
part in the decision-making process the
feature is somewhat similar to the way
games like whiplash handle multiplayer
turning on crowd play will generate a
unique URL that the primary player can
then share with anyone they want to play
with players with the URL will then be
able to open it on their phones or other
devices which will see them added as
participants to the game when the
primary player comes to a choice in
Batman crowd players will vote as to
which choice they think the player
should make the primary player can
enable two modes as to how these votes
will be handled the first will see the
option with the most votes being the
final decision while the second will
display a life percentage of how the
crowd has voted but the decision will
remain completely up to the player crowd
players will also have the ability to
thumbs up or down players decisions in
real-time this obviously sounds like the
perfect tool for streamers but the
developers have noted that the stream
latency could be an issue for live
voting with the thumbs up or down being
the most viable mode at least for the
moment crowd play will be available in
all telltale games going forward
Batman the telltale series will see
players assuming the role of both Bruce
Wayne and Batman in a fresh
interpretation of the universe not tied
to any existing iteration of the
characters the first episode releases on
August 2 and we'll be playing it live so
make sure to swing by GameSpot so we can
all make bad decisions together